des annonces particulièrement attendue
qui reste assez flou est une question
qui reste en suspens à l'arrivée de
nouveaux variants en france va-t-elle
provoquer l'instauration d'un troisième
confinement une possibilité qui reste
sur la table selon olivier ferrand
même si la fermeture des écoles n'est
pas envisagée si nous devions constater
qu'il y aurait davantage de variants
anglais et que nous étions sur une pente
de épidémique al anglaise par exemple ou
si nous constations que malgré le
couvre-feu de 18h la pression sanitaire
la saturation des hôpitaux devaient
augmenter alors nous pourrions être
amenés à prendre des mesures plus dures
telles que celles que les français ont
déjà connu pendant l'automne c'est à
dire ça peut aller jusqu'à un
confinement si la situation devait
l'exiger
autre sujet attendu la réouverture des
remontées mécaniques
selon olivier ferrand peu de chance pour
les professionnels de la montagne de
retrouver le chemin des stations même
sort pour les parents
torrent le ministre de la santé a
également abordé la campagne de
vaccination en france
largement critiqué depuis ses débuts
olivier ferrand a évoqué une forme d'
enthousiasme des français alors que
certains centres de vaccination se sont
retrouvé submergé par les demandes de
rendez vous face à la pénurie de doses
de vaccins constatée en france le
ministre de la santé a annoncé une
publication en toute transparence sur
les stocks disponibles dans chaque
centre et a assuré que l'intégralité de
la population française seraient
vaccinés d'ici 2021 à partir de mardi
nous rouvrons 500 mille places de
vaccination entre le milieu et la fin du
mois de février
ensuite nous avons toujours dit aux
français que nous ne pouvons pas
vacciner tout le monde tout de suite il
y a huit millions de français qui sont
total appelé au total appelées à se
faire vacciner entre les personnes âgées
en ehpad les soignants de 50 ans et plus
les personnes âgées de 75 ans et plus
les personnes très vulnérables au regard
de leur santé et nous avons dit très
clairement qu'à la fin du mois de
janvier nous aurions fait normalement un
million de vaccinations je peux vous
dire ce soir que nous en ferons
davantage probablement 1 millions 3,1
millions 4 vaccination redouté par les
français un troisième confinement est
pourtant largement réclamé par la
communauté scientifique afin de lutter
contre les variants ducobu 19